[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره نقلت وسائل
الاعلام ان موليه لنظام السوريه ان
الطيران التركيه سنه خمسه غارات على مواقع
لما تعرفوا بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
الشماليه سوريا ولوح الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان بهجوم المريخ قائلا ان بلاده
ستهاجم ما وصفها بمواقع الارهابيين ودفع
الرئيس التركي عن حق بلاده في الدفاع عن
امنها
بدعم ما وصفها بالمنظمات الارهابيه
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان الاعمال
العسكريه في شمال سوريا تهدده مهمه الحاق
الهزيمه بتنظيم الدوله وقال منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكيين لدى تركيا الحاقه في
الدفاع عن نفسها لكنه اعرب عن خشته من
تقويض القدره على قتال تنظيم الدوله
وداع الكريم لان الحكومه التركيه الى عدم
استخدام القوه المفرطه في سوريا واقل
المبعوث الروسي الى سوريا انه من الضروري
البحث عن حل السلمي للقضيه الكرديه
اعلنت ايران وبدات تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
60% بمنشاه فردو وتركيبه اجهزه طرد
المركزي جديده واقل التسلطات الايرانيه
انها ستضخ الغاز في الاجهزه الجديده جاء
ذلك ردا على اتهام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه للطيران بعدم التعاون معها وتعهد
بيان بريطانيا فرنسي الماني بمواجهه
مواصفه بالتصعيد النووي الايراني
بدوره قال المبعوث الامريكي لايران روبرت
مالي للجزيره ان تصعد فهران متوقع لا في
ثانيه لان جميع الخيارات تبقى متاحه لدى
واشنطن اذا لم تنجح الدبلوماسيه
وقع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه مع النائب
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني اعلان خطاب
نياتهم بشان التعاون الثنائي وذلك في ختام
جلسات الحوار الاستراتيجيه الخامس بين
البلدين وقال وزير الخارجيه القطريين
المباحثات شملت لملف النوويه الايراني
وقضايا العراق وليبيا وافغانستان وفلسطين
من جانبه اكد لينكن اهميه الشراكه
وانهار الصراعات الاقليميه والدوله
حقق المنتخب السعودي و فوزا تاريخيا على
نظيره الارجنتيني بهدفين بهدف في المجموعه
الثالثه لكاس العالم قطر 2022 وقد احتسب
حكم اللقاء ركله جزاء للمنتخب الارجنتيني
سجل منها ليونيل ميسي هدف منتخب بلاده
الاول والوحيد وفي بدايه الشوط الثاني
ادرك المنتخب السعودي التعادل ثم اضاف
الهدف الثاني
واستهل المنتخب التونسي ومشواره في
المونديال بالتعادل ثمين دون اهداف امام
نظيره جدا
على المنتخب التونسي فرصا عديده لكن هو
فقط في تحويلها الى اهداف لتنتهي المباراه
بالتعادل السلبي
اشكركم على متابعتي هذا الموجز السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]